une autre fête pas à paris l'événement à
saumur hier soir se passait autour de la
table manifestation originale dans la
capitale du saumur champigny 4500
personnes en fait ripaille autour de
cochonnailles le banquet faisait 2 km
christophe devals ambras philippe
ritaine était du festin les veinards à
la seconde près il est l'heure de passer
à table
la fanfare sonne le début de banquets et
qu'elle banquet rabelais venu en voisin
n'aurait pas renier l'ambiance ils sont
quatre mille cinq cents convives de
kilomètres de table à la gloire de la
cochonnaille et du vin local
pas plus ok lasting
avec ce vin là monsieur en anjou ont
fait des centenaires wu laissant faire à
ne plus savoir qu'en faire et avec plus
de 3000 bouteilles vides et hier soir ça
devrait durer
il ya quatre ans la première édition de
cette désormais grandes tablées ne
réunissait que quelques privilégiés
autour d'un casse-croûte estivale
une histoire d'amitié entre un
viticulteur et un charcutier on a
associé les boulangers les petits fous
et marchand de fromages et jean bignon
après tout le monde nous a sauvés mais
voyez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment moi notre image de marque pas
ce que l'on fait on fait la vitrine de
saumur la convivialité la bonne bouffe
est en fait la fête
et puis surtout en pleine saison
touristique cette grande table est une
formidable opération de promotion pour
l'instar des produits locaux au niveau
national anglais ya des italiens je sais
qu'aider aussi des hindous c'est
merveilleux quand même regarder elle est
pas belle la vie
les grandes tablées est une célébration
de la convivialité
elle sera de nouveau dressé l'été
prochain pour le plaisir